faze clan has suspended three members
and booted one
entirely over their involvement in a
shady
pump and dump cryptocurrency scheme
we've remained in contact with them and
we we've asked them like well i have
personally asked them you yo
where where's the response why have you
guys not addressed this yet what is
going on
do not believe what you're hearing
online if you don't know what
coffeezilla is man this dude there is
right there goes into the trenches
the people behind this coin at least
from what it appears to be running a
standard pump and dump
is not only disgusting but it actually
makes me sick to my [ __ ] stomach why
is he listening to the influencers
telling him you need to change the thing
that's preventing this from being a scam
to one minute thereby making it a scam
and face case not
innocent but uh there are a lot of other
people
that are guilty that there is like some
type of mastermind here
who's the name tell me
well this is awkward i didn't plan on
talking to you guys until
my next installment on save the kids
because this story is not over
i don't know if you guys remember how he
left it but we still don't know who the
true
mastermind is but in this new video that
i've been working on
i've been digging deep to unveil the
truth
about save the kids and i think we found
most of it i teamed up
with some ordinary gamers to look
closely over the blockchain
to find out who's truly responsible in
fact he just uploaded a one
hour video exposing some of what we
found but that's not even
all of it and all i want to do is tell
you guys
that story right tell you the story of
how influencers with 50 million
followers
could be behind a coin called save the
kids
which did anything but and instead scam
the fans
who invested instead of that though
today i got
something from our boy phase k
sorry x phase k and after repeatedly
reaching out to him for comment on the
new evidence that i had found
i got this this is a cease and desist
letter from
frasier k's lawyers basically they're
saying you know
we're gonna sue you if you don't hold on
let's see here um
if you do not immediately by the end of
the day tomorrow at the latest publicly
retract the defamatory statements and
cease and desist from making
other such defamatory statements in the
future okay
well that tomorrow they're talking about
is actually today
which is why i'm making this video to
inform the boys at uh
fraser's law firm that unfortunately i'm
gonna miss the deadline boys
because even though of course i don't
want to get sued this is nothing
but bullying to try to get me to shut up
about exposing one of the biggest crypto
scams this year and even though keeping
my video up means apparently
i'm getting sued for millions of dollars
they tell me
my conscience is clean i'll happily
fight this in court
and listen i'm not gonna hide behind
lawyers here instead i'm gonna walk you
through this
absolute toilet paper i'll show you the
ridiculous bullying that these guys are
trying to do to get me to shut up and
not only that i'm gonna let you in on a
little secret opinion of mine
that this lawsuit is a tactic to silence
the new evidence that's coming out about
kay
he knows the kind of things that i have
on him and he knows it because i've been
asking him for comment
on it and he hasn't been responding
apparently he's been prepping
his lawyers to come at me instead but
that's going to backfire on them because
today i'll be sharing
a taste of that info with you including
a brand new phase k wallet
that nobody knew about but first let's
deal with this
little legal letter here at the risk of
boring you
i'll be posting the full letter on my
twitter account if you want to see it
there but i'll just be going over
the most important parts here we are the
litigation
council for fraser cadrotti aka
face k we write to you regarding your
false and defamatory public statements
about mr cadrotti
since june 2021 and demand that you
immediately retract them in as public a
manner as you have made them
they go on to say that i'm not only
defame frazier k
they also say i've extorted him which
was news to me
listen to this they say um to whit you
wrote
k i'm serious man this is our dm's by
the way i guess um
asking for comment is extortion now i'm
serious man you gotta start talking
we've found so much more on you and if
you keep hiding behind these ridiculous
two-minute statements
it's never gonna work if you guys don't
know i'm referencing phase k's um
response video where he didn't say sorry
and instead
tried to play the victim but hold on
we'll continue here
i said not only that we want to take
down pepper but you staying silent
isn't helping okay here i'm discussing
the fact most people
involved in this investigation know
pepper's involved and
we know that k knows that so we're
looking for that evidence i'm just
asking him
look share that information with us now
listen to this they say
despite knowing that sam pepper was the
bad actor here
not mr cadrotti okay so apparently i'm
asking for evidence on sam pepper being
the bad guy while
apparently knowing that sam pepper was
the bad guy and this constitutes
extortion so let me make break this down
for you guys at home
asking for comment on new evidence
saying hey
because we had lost communication he
just stopped responding my messages and
i'm saying
look we have new evidence you need to
respond to it it looks
terrible right that apparently is
extortion according to phase k
this demonstrates your malicious intent
and willingness to report
false facts to comport with what you
perceive to as your best interest
again what do i know as facts i'm asking
phase k
for the facts on sam pepper and i'm
being told that's extortion
but also i knew the facts that
k won't provide me like
what are you talking about dude here's
the thing that pisses me off this whole
time they're saying like
basically i'm purposely misleading
people
in order to you know get the craziest
headline possible
but if that were true i would have just
said everyone involved
was equally bad i didn't instead i went
through everyone's wallets that i had
and said you know how bad i thought it
was faze jarvis phase nikon
not as bad as phase k right face
tico i've publicly exonerated because i
had a look at his wallet
he talked because he's innocent and it
was proven that he hadn't sold
his save the kids token so if what
they're saying is true and i'm looking
to
promote myself and your videos rather
than conducting a factually supportable
and careful review of the truth as any
reputable reporter would have done
i would have just thrown everyone under
the bus instead i pointed out the people
who had a habit of pumping and dumping
and i pointed out the people who didn't
and all the while i asked everyone
for comment because of course in a case
that is this serious
i have to ask you is there more
information of the story they also tell
me
that i made among other
attention-grabbing false and defamatory
statements about
mr cadrotti let's take a listen mr
khadrati
aka k engaged in malicious
selling is what i said yeah i would i'd
actually say that's true
i mean what are you talking about you
sold save the kids which you were an
ambassador of in 24 hours how is that
not malicious selling
you're supposed to be an ambassador of a
charity token and you sold everything in
24 hours they also say i said
he dumped all his kids tokens
immediately
also true but here's a good one they
also included a joke i put in
my video they said i said phase k should
be called
phase rug actually that's a good joke
what i mean by that
is that he not only sold save the kids
instantly he has a history of doing that
to every or nearly every project he gets
involved
in you can check it for yourself on the
blockchain boys
and it kind of just continues like that
um but here's another one that's kind of
important to talk about
they're apparently upset because i said
it's all leading back to phase k
which it was because manny and lucas
they're talking about face k
who himself is insisting oh no i didn't
make any money
that he's the victim in all this okay
there i'm just
quoting what he told me again because i
asked him
for comment which i shouldn't have even
done in the first place apparently
because it's extorting phase k
i'm sorry i keep calling him face sorry
k i'm not trying to dig that in i just
just have it they're saying i'm
extorting k by asking him for a comment
so
the very fact that he got to say in my
video that oh no i didn't make any money
and that he claimed to be a victim
is because of this thing that i did
which is asking for a comment
so they conclude we demand that you
cease and desist if you do not
mr khadrati has instructed us to
commence litigation against you and
all those with whom you act are acting
in concert
and or have been supplying you with
false and defamatory
information wow um maybe some ordinary
gamers
because we researched this thing
together so they might be hearing from
this guy's lawyers too
got a cease and desist and they're
saying that anybody who's
who's helped work on this might be sued
i mean we'll have to take it to court
but that also means the discovery phase
and that also means
whoever is really behind this and the
true inner workings of save the kids is
going to get exposed and
i have a pretty good feeling that it's
not going to be good for the party
that's
suing they say among other damages your
false statements have caused phase to
terminate
mr khadrati's relationship with it and
mr khadrati may as a result lose
millions of dollars of revenue
and that's of course what they're suing
me for see here's the thing
their lawsuit is saying i cause this i'm
the i'm the guy
responsible for getting k removed from
faze clan because face gland had no
involvement with our members activity
on the cryptocurrency space but you know
who actually
already admitted to this not me i didn't
say it phase k himself
came out prematurely you know before i
even had time to make my big video
and said confess to his altcoin thing he
said himself it was irresponsible for me
to speak publicly about coins
without knowing more look so you're
admitting what you did
you got you kicked out of face clan you
know what i mean like
you promoting cryptocurrencies and
rugging your followers
got you kicked out of faze clan i had
nothing to do with it i'm just the guy
who caught you
along with my boys some ordinary gamers
and barely sociable
like honestly it's so insulting that
he's implying here
that faze clan can't do their own
investigation like it's an insult to
your own company
that um you were just kicked out of
because they suspended other people but
they kicked you out meaning they thought
what you did was worse and that's their
decision i mean i didn't call faze clan
telling them you know what what to do
right they're making their own decisions
based on what they want to do
and you're upset about it and you're
trying to blame me but honestly that's
not a surprise because frazier failing
to take responsibility for his actions
seems to be a recurring theme see have
you guys seen this video
titled the truth about save the kids
this was released by frasier after
a long um wait instead of bringing
evidence he brought a two-minute video
where he never apologized and said once
again that he's the victim
i know i haven't posted in a while and
there is so much that i want to say
about what's happened in the past month
but because of legal reasons
all i'm allowed to say right legal
reasons
like suing me i guess now is this please
please do not believe what you're
hearing online all of these people
making videos
think that they know the truth and that
they know who's responsible
when they just don't honestly this thing
is so embarrassing
he's saying he wants the truth out there
but he's tangled up in legal stuff
while trying to tangle the people who
are talking also
up in legal stuff so they can't say
anything so he refuses to give any
information to anyone
and he refuses to let anyone else get
any information out otherwise he might
sue you and i know that sounds bad but
let's give frazier a break he says he's
found the guy
responsible there's one bad guy so we've
uncovered significant
evidence which confirms that a dishonest
person abused his trust with me to scam
everybody he's talking about sam pepper
but he's afraid to say his name
now this is a predictable but ultimately
futile decision to try to blame
everything on sam pepper
why not because sam pepper's innocent
he's definitely
not i've known he's not i've been asking
frasier for information
to confirm that by the way for a long
time the reason it's stupid
is because sam pepper and fraser have
been running around
in crypto doing these scams for a very
long time
and they run in a lot of the same
circles in fact i'm about to show you
one of these scams right now live and
mind you this is ten percent of what i
have i had to make
put this video together in one night
because i have to respond
to this before apparently they're gonna
sue or whatever
um so just so you guys know this is ten
percent of what we got and this will
directly contradict frazier's little
goofy theory
that sam pepper you know abused his
trust
and that oh k k didn't know what was
going on right like
how how has he he been involved in this
stuff before no he's just an innocent
naive crypto investor
so let's talk about moon pug moon pug
was
yet another scam where the developers
had most of the liquidity
and people got rugged pretty quick in
fact
this scam was so bad that even sam
pepper himself
felt bad about what he did to his fans
he said in a tweet yesterday i spent all
day hyping up the fact i was going to
promote a
tweet a token and like if'd up
i chose one that was pre-sale thinking
people would like
that they are getting in early but
instead this made it unfair
after it went live people saw the devs
held huge wallets this was stupid on my
part
not to check this and left people
feeling like the project was a scam
so this thing was so sleazy that even
sam pepper
is like yikes now with that background
on moon pug
pay attention to this avatar that is
something called a shadow people
sam pepper promoted these nfts you know
who bought one of these nfts
take a look phase k new verified shadow
people collector and just underneath it
to verify it even more phase k
response with the devil emoji quite
appropriate
now you guys should be familiar with the
rest of this process using
this nft number i just cross check the
time of sale
and find out uh who owned it at the time
that would be
this wallet right here now all we have
to do is cross
check the bsc scan go to the bat 20
token section and
boom see he participated in moon pug
he got money from the deployer wallet
meaning he was involved before the
public could be and what did this guy do
when he got
loaded up with tons of moonpot well
he dumped it as fast as he possibly
could
in a little over four hours this guy got
rid of
all his moon puck which means that if we
go to the day of launch we can
watch as frasier dumps his coins here's
the start of the sale
he gets in early it pumps really high he
sells off
hour two hour three hour four
and by this hour he's out now remember
that
as we zoom out this guy got in around
here
sold all the way here is completely out
of the coin
and of course everyone gets wiped out
and the truth is the amount of money he
made
wasn't trivial i went transaction by
transaction
finding how much money he made each time
he kept trading
for tin wrapped bnb with a total of
20 out transactions that means he made
about
200 b b which at a b b price of 523
dollars
means he made about a hundred thousand
dollars
off of selling this moon pug in the
first few hours this is why
i'm so sick of frazier claiming to be
naive
naive people don't know how to rug a
coin
naive people usually don't have multiple
wallets
and naive people sure as hell don't know
how to make a hundred thousand dollars
from a pre-sell of a [ __ ] coin so in
conclusion i want to close this
by saying that in my opinion okay you
are a self-serving
hypocrite you claim in your response
video that you just want to help people
and get to the bottom of this and one
way i can pay that forward is by making
sure that this con man
gets the justice that he deserves but
that isn't true is it
in reality you're trying to sue people
who are investigating
this whole thing all the while claiming
you're gonna do
your own investigation we're conducting
a very thorough
independent and aggressive investigation
how could it be
independent you're like one of the main
guys
yo i know i was accused of this but i'm
going to investigate it individually
what and how is it aggressive you didn't
do anything
until we made videos about it and you
got in trouble and look
i get it you're upset you got caught and
now you're trying to use
your vast resources to shut up the
people who are looking into what you've
done
and meanwhile you're not responding to
comment and if anyone asks
for comment you say they're extorting
you but in my opinion the people you're
really betraying here
is not me it's your fans right like the
least you could do is apologize to them
for what you've done and you haven't
done that right like not once during
this thing does
kay apologize he doesn't say sorry
instead he throws
sam pepper onto the bus which i'm not
saying sam pepper's innocent he even
could be the mastermind as i said a week
ago
we don't know right i'm looking into it
i'm asking everybody
but let's not pretend that k and sam
haven't been involved in
the crypto game for a while now so i'm
gonna close this video
by addressing kay i guess um look
no puny lawsuit threat is gonna make me
stop investigating getting to the truth
of this
and the reason for that is because i
know
all you have is money you have piles and
piles of money no one's disputing that
clearly we just you know
but what you don't have is the truth
because if you did have that
you'd be standing up loudly talking to
anyone who would listen
instead anyone who asks you questions is
apparently extorting you
so i don't know that's all i basically
have to say good luck throwing your
piles of money around
and in the meantime i'll just continue
my investigation to everyone else who's
out there listening
quite dramatic i apologize i hope that i
can just get back to work
keep investigating and i'll be
presenting you guys with a new video
exposing the truth about save the kids
very
seemed soon but a trick trying to sell
me on a dream but
that was where you lost me wake up and
smell the coffee